rapid covet testing at home is already a
reality in the united kingdom and it
could soon happen here as well the white
house has a billion dollar plan to make
over-the-counter tests widely available
here in america charlie daggett has more
now from london on what we might expect
charlie good morning to you
hey tony i've got a test right here
actually a box of tests i keep a bunch
at home my daughter had to test before
she went to school i test before going
on assignment here they have become a
way of life
b banks and school friend izzy rivers
are perfectly healthy teenagers yet like
a lot of students across england they
test for covid twice a week and why do
you test
because then
back positive
you've got to stay at home like if you
don't test then you'll never know that
you actually have it and then by that
time it'll be too late and you'll have
infected other people at home testing
has become as routine here as brushing
your teeth and packing your books for
school are you surprised when i tell you
that hardly any american students
i think that's really weird like i guess
like i wouldn't feel i'm more like less
safe going to school but i feel more
like worried like you wouldn't know if
anyone had it
in the early days of kovid scientists
posed an interesting question what if
everybody and i mean everybody could
just test themselves at home whether
they're going to school or weddings or a
big party that's been a reality here for
months and getting a test kit is
literally this easy
time
might please get a covered test kit of
course would you like one or two ah two
please
there you go thank you how much do i owe
you they're free
yeah
thank you free if you can even find one
in the us they're 12
for one test these kits contain seven
rapid antigen tests and they're
unlimited
tests that can identify roughly 98
of infectious covid cases and have
slowed down the spread of the virus in
europe epidemiologist tim spector you
know this is a really good extra tool
you know in our kit to fight covid it
reassures people it's easy to do and
it's not perfect by any means but it
just gives you
extra knowledge you know if you are
testing negative all the time that you
are safe the fda announced last week
that it would allow the sale of similar
antigen tests and the white house has
pledged that 200 million rapid at-home
tests per month will be available
starting in december and it's not just
schools parents test two i went to the
theater last week and they asked us to
test for them
and occasionally
hockey club i play hockey so they'll say
please can you test before you come and
have teas at the social club so quite
regularly it may soon become part of
daily life in the u.s one more weapon to
stop the spread so
to american students who are watching
this who thinking god that's going to be
weird what would you say i guess like it
seems like such a big thing like shoving
anything up your nose and down your
throat but it's not that big of a deal
like you just
you do it and then it's done
as the professor said it's all about
reassurance you know you've got cold and
flu season coming up if you wake up with
the sniffles feeling a bit black go
ahead and take a test it'll make you and
those around you feel that bit safer
gail
all right charlie i say the more tools
the better thank you reporting from
london